[Musique]
pour sa traditionnelle foire de la
saint-simon la commune de château fort a
fait un saut dans le passé le temps
d'une journée le village a retrouvé ses
habits du moyen âge c'est surtout
l'occasion de permettre aux villageois
de se regrouper un jour par an autour
d'un événement qui fédère un peu le
village
[Musique]
nous recherchons ce qui les packs été
utilisé à l'époque surtout pour les
danses de cour mais après tout ce qui
est dense paysanne bas c'est plutôt la
gaieté la joie de vivre la bonne humeur
la convivialité en plus des animations
un campement médiéval était installé
l'occasion de parfaire sa culture
historique à ce cas là on va le grand 1
qui est un petit peu en pointe oui allez
des trous il ya une raison d'une raison
c'est la ventilation on essaie de tordre
le cou à pas mal d'idées préconçues
véhiculée par ma part le cinéma le
spectacle et voilà j'ai donc essayé de
reprendre des éléments de l'histoire
c'est un voyage dans le temps
or on se retrouve au moyen-âge entouré
de chevalier de gueux de courtisanes et
il ya toujours quelque chose à apprendre
sur place tous les troisièmes samedis du
mois d'octobre ce sont près de 10000
visiteurs qui viennent se plonger dans
le passé médiéval de châteaufort
[Musique]